it's incredible how jacked you are
there's the thing you first of all I
don't blame you if I had your body I
would be shirtless all the time you are
shirtless constantly on television
appearances in movies even we have you
were at a celebrity all-star game yes
you're sure you have to make up an
excuse like oh it's getting hot you
wouldn't have to unbutton it you could
flex and your trip adult and the budget
would pop out but there was one legal
problem yes but the thing you know you
have to be to me fashion is is shirtless
it starts certainly wait a minute what
you time that this is real
you're saying real fashion is being
shirtless real fashion if you look good
shirtless oh when that shirt comes on
baby
it's gonna be hot my whole thing is you
know my wife was really tired of it and
it's okay
the kids are a little embarrassed but
hey it's working right but you're saying
if you don't know what to wear
let's say you're going to a banquet or a
fancy event you don't know what to wear
did you just go shirtless
I would I would rather go to a funeral
and show up ago like I'm very sorry for
your loss take off this shirt for the
brother that ain't here you know
says I'm taking off a shirt for the
brothers up here it just doesn't work
that way
well I am clothed at all times that's
how we are different
this is covered constantly because it
should be you were impressed right you
know I was impressed by with that you're
hurting but you know I was expecting a
wet noodle and I got rigatoni
yeah it's strong noodles so that's the
thicker nari thick new thank you very
much thank you very much you know it's
funny you you were very serious about
your workout and you work out how much a
day is it nine ten hours will do two
hours a day two hours a day Andy Daly at
the gym this morning it's so not our
second guess it's so crazy I'm always at
the gym so I just see it was at the gym
dude I'm sorry he's really funny but
what's he there like installing the
phone I didn't even notice him actually
he told me backstage I was at the gym I
was like I walked right by you but yeah
yeah he was trapped under a weight
[Laughter]
you